[SPEAKER_01]: At 2 p.m. on the 4th of Wealsun, Paul Rivero exits the Warrens with his prisoners returning to the Alchemy building.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you walk into the thing and your guys walk by and the sergeant that was with you says, here, these are prisoners for the Royal Dungeons.
[SPEAKER_01]: I assume you can take these, captain.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he says that to Rodiger.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Rodiger says, men, they go and grab them.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he comes up to you and says, Sir, we found the body of an old man.
[SPEAKER_01]: The fire's been put out.
[SPEAKER_01]: We found the body of an old man and the sewer's below the building.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Take them back to the Royal Dungeon.
[SPEAKER_00]: Show me where the body is, please.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, come this way.
[SPEAKER_01]: You walk into the building, the smell of fire still there, and actually the stench of the chemicals in the area, pretty acrid to the nose.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, the place is not as damaged as you would have thought it was, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: You walk down this spiral staircase into the sewers where there's this running river that goes from the harbor district and then it turns towards the seawall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, this is the way the sewage in the city is moved off.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And there on the stone walkway at the bottom of the stairs, you see the old man.
[SPEAKER_01]: Laying there with a stab wound in his eye and some weird black acre coming out of the wound.
[SPEAKER_01]: A black like ooze?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like some kind of poison.
[SPEAKER_00]: The skin is discolorized.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to take a vial if I can and get that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so you tell Rodiger, fetch me, you know there are vials upstairs.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fetch me a vial from upstairs.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what do you do?
[SPEAKER_01]: You look?
[SPEAKER_00]: I kind of bend down and I just look, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this is the old alchemist?
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the alchemist.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's obviously been killed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyway, Rodiger comes down with the vial.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I assume you take it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you take your dagger and scoop something in?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a weird liquid.
[SPEAKER_01]: Black.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it almost flows like mercury.
[SPEAKER_01]: Weird.
[SPEAKER_01]: Into the test tube.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you get a little dropper of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And you sit there looking at it in the torch light that Rodiger holds above you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very strange little BB of blackness.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically quicksilver, but dark.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, there is a shimmer to it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very strange.
[SPEAKER_01]: Weird.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Rodiger says to you, do you know what that is?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I don't.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll find out, though.
[SPEAKER_01]: You take it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cap it off.
[SPEAKER_01]: And put it in your pouch.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there anything else on the walls, on the drawers, or anything like that that's so important?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you don't see anything in the sewer.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, we're in the sewer?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you had to go down into the sewer.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's where the guy's body was.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to have it taken out, or what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I'll just hold onto that myself.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want his body taken out?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, have his body taken out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to give orders to...
[SPEAKER_00]: Rodiger?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: Rodiger, take this body out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where should I have it taken?
[SPEAKER_00]: I want it to be analyzed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Take it back to the royal palace?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, please.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, under my name.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have the cards.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I was told that Jude went down these sewers.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there any means that I can tell which way they went?
[SPEAKER_01]: Did they come back the way they came?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: The only way out is through the pipes, and he points to the rivulet that goes towards the sea.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's possible they fell in the water and went downstream.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where they ended up, I don't know, there are grates on all of the pipes that go through the sewers.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are other places they may have been able to come out, manholes and such.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um...
[SPEAKER_00]: If I were a Jew, what would I do?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'd probably kill someone, but...
[SPEAKER_01]: If he could.
[SPEAKER_00]: If he could.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he's with some other boy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, I think the best move is to just go back to my palace.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you go with Rodiger and the rest of the troops, with the prisoners, and walk up the row of gods.
[SPEAKER_01]: Towards the palace, trying your best to act like one of the guardsmen instead of trying to be Paul Rivero.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why do I try to act to be a guard member?
[SPEAKER_01]: If you don't want to, if you want people to know that Paul Rivero is down there with a mask, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nah, it's okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll just go back and...
[SPEAKER_00]: To be honest, I don't really care.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's at nighttime anyways.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, there are people on the street watching.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you walk back to the Royal Palace.